one phenomenon in recent years
especially post the George Floyd
incidents but even predating that has
been the rise of what has been known as
the progressive prosecutor in several
large American cities
um criminal justice reform-minded DA's
and a couple years ago I talked with
George gascon who was the former police
officer who became D.A in San Francisco
and then La I am curious what your
reaction is to what gascon had to say we
have convinced our community for years
that over incarceration and more police
presence and more prosecutions actually
was leading to Greater safety when in
fact it has probably led to Greater
insecurity de-emphasizing the criminal
process when it comes to low-level
non-violent offense is actually
increases safety in general not just for
those types of crimes but even for more
serious crime what should the
consequences actually be well I I say
clear and almost use the term
consequences because when people say in
town because I don't your money to get
housing criminalizing that behavior I
think is not only immoral I believe that
it doesn't fix the problem right so I
would say that rather than consequences
I like to use a term you know the right
intervention to summarize gascon's
argument there it's that the police are
generally the wrong intervention for a
lot of what is going wrong in public
spaces and that there should be either a
more robust social safety net or some
other organization that intervenes in
certain circumstances I'm sure you've
heard this argument a lot what's your
reply to it I support that argument most
complete sheets most cops who have to
deal with all of this the emotionally
disturbed the homeless the uh the
narcotics addicted would like to get out
of the business to of something that
they're not trained adequately to deal
with that they're working with laws that
are inappropriate so where gascon's
coming from and for purposes your
audience people need to understand
George kiscon was my number two in the
LAPD for most of my time as chief of
police I supported him when he went to
Mesa as chief of police in Mesa I
supported his appointment as chief of
police in San Francisco but I do not
support most of his ideas since he has
now gone over to the progressive
district attorney wing of uh government
uh you cannot show me one city in
America that has one of these
Progressive District Attorneys were well
intended and we share the belief that
Criminal Justice Reform is necessary we
share the belief that there are a lot of
alternatives to using the police for a
lot of these social ills but until we
fund them adequately till we coordinate
and organize them adequately police are
left as the agency of Last Resort to
deal with them that's the reality and
you cannot find one city in America
Philadelphia
Los Angeles certainly
that has one of these Progressive DA's
that are funded by the George Soros open
Society Foundation instead of having
success in reducing crime or disorder
they're all a mess and they're well
intended but the their policies and
procedures are actually not reducing
crime or disorder this stuff is not
rocket science it's the I know
understand your history what worked what
didn't work and uh what I worry about
unfortunately over the next two years is
we're going into the Silly Season we're
going into the next presidential
election and we're effectively got two
totally Divergent perspectives very far
to the left on one hand the Democrats
very proud of the fight on the fight the
Republicans uh you need to get more
people to to Center ground to comment
explain what what is the problem when
you say very far to the left and that's
a problem what what is the definitive
mistake that people on the left are
making and on the left it is the idea of
continued attacks on police the idea of
undermining the legitimacy of police is
does policing have its flaws does the
profession have its issues like every
profession it does but without I've been
in it for 50 some odd years and believe
me what it was back in 1970 is not what
it was in our 19 2023. on the right the
issue is this rise of uh militarism the
uh in terms of the the proud boys and
this anger at government but when I talk
about the file Labs I mentioned also I
would go back to George fascone and the
progressive DA's well-intended
but with the results where were where
were their policies and procedures
they're keeping a lot of people out of
jail great
but we have more murder victims we have
more rape victims we have more people
being high more cities being made less
safe uh if they were showing success
in terms of reduced crime in victims uh
I'd be I'd be celebrating them I have no
problem with a lot of the reforms they
want to put in place but the way they
join them not working on the far right
the idea of War crops War crops is not
the solution unless those crops are
highly trained you think Memphis is
going to benefit by hiring more cops
like those five that they just hired in
the last couple of years certainly not
um I think the response that the
progressive prosecutors and their
supporters would have is that your uh or
one response is that your approach even
if it can you can show some uh empirical
results with it the the other side of
the empirical equation there is that
when you kind of flood the Zone with
more police officers and tell them to go
more aggressively intervene
um in the you know problem areas that
the inevitable results of that is that
more people in minority communities more
blacks and Latinos are going to have
more interactions with police more
unwanted interactions with police and I
mean that has been borne out by the the
data you know that they that those
communities disproportionately then get
more uh you know interface with the
police and they're there's inevitably
going to be people who who aren't doing
anything who are walking down the street
getting harassed suddenly I don't deny
that this whole conversation has been
about how to deal with that again I'll
speak to my own time my own record in
the sense of I don't apologize for uh
any of my years in policing in the sense
of 95 96 did we encourage more arrests
yes because that was going to be
necessary to stop the fairways in the
subway to stop the 2000 murders on the
streets the 5 000 people shot in the
streets of New York the half million
people victims of serious crime in New
York I'm very proud that by 2019 before
the state legislation started messing it
up again there were fewer than a hundred
thousand for the first time in history
fewer than a hundred thousand reported
crimes in a city that had now grown from
seven and a half million to eight and a
half million people in a city that has
also become much more minority majority
than it was back in 1994. so it can be
made safer everywhere for everyone I
think I I've got a lot of uh if you will
proof of that I think a lot of the ideas
that I promulgate that I basically with
a lot of the time I spent with Kellen
that I promulgated my book uh there are
ways to deal with this to deal with the
issues of race and races Central to all
of this in terms of dealing with the
police I just did an event last night
with Connie rice from uh the Civil Right
advocate in Los Angeles who have got a
great partnership with and was very
helpful with me in Los Angeles trying to
get the base issue in Los Angeles under
control for 50 years the LAPD terrorized
the black community in Los Angeles no
denying it politically as well as uh uh
using the police and we were able to
turn that around turned around fairly
dramatically hey that's an excerpt from
our reason live stream with Bill Bratton
who was New York City's top cop he also
worked in LA and oversaw dramatic
decreases in crime we talked about
what's going on now what worked in the
past what might work in the future and
how do you square all of that with the
need for civil liberties if you want to
watch the whole video check it out
and if you want to check out our recent
live streams we do them every Thursday
at Zach weismiller and I at 1 pm eastern
time go to reason.com and check us out